hi my name is Barry Gao and I'm a
prosthetic makeup designer for film and
television
[Music]
so being a prosthetic makeup designer
I'm basically responsible for the
practical special makeup effects
creating character makeups and fantasy
characters and we do an awful lot of
trauma and blood and gore as well I
design a lot of the looks for the
makeups and I'm responsible for various
parts and various little departments
along the way with almost every project
when we were approached about work we're
usually given the script or if it's TV
show we're given an outline of the whole
series and we'll basically sit and read
through break down what might be
practical what might be digital and we
basically then have meetings with
directors and producers talk about the
characters and see what they think is
probably going to be in camera what
might work might be done post editorial
I mean there are some directors who know
exactly what they want or they've got a
specific idea in mind or maybe they've
worked with a concept designer who's
come up with some stuff and you're
basically just making it where you get
given a design you just make it if it's
something like a gory effect you don't
tend to need to do designs if it's more
of a creature or something like miking
then that will have been designed while
it does get to use all of them some
illustrations we would start the design
process with concept designs and
sometimes we doing the cats clay
maquette
which we can shred in the
three-dimensional sculpture once they
liked the look of it then costume
involved and then other departments
resolved that but in the initial
instance it's usually just Barry sending
messages having meetings of the director
to decide what well for each of these
characters which has quite expensive
prosthetic makeups that all bespoke
actor stunt performer and it involves
quite a lengthy process from the design
to sculpture nor all the production of
the actual aesthetics to then the
application onset each day so the first
thing we do is live past an actor most
commonly a head that can be any body
part or a full body I'd generally leave
that and then we get a plaster out of
that which would go to sculptors they
sculpt their makeup on it and in the
meantime I'll get another plaster now
the live class mold and make a splayed
core so this is a sculpt on a core this
is the epoxy cause remake for them and
they cancel member fiberglass on the
back this is made from a section of the
actors face after that and plaster this
is a back inside of a head with an ear
on it
the sculptors already put the sculpt on
it and just starting to mold it now so
the first thing we do is cover the layer
al Jinnah and then what tissue protect
it the next thing we put a now apply on
top of this and then I'll divide it in
sections with steel shims should really
fill in sheet steel and then I'll
fiberglass the whole thing will drill
bolt holes in it so I can develop it
down to the core trim it take it all off
then we clean the clay out put an mp5
glass back on and in the space where the
clay was we fill with silicon and that's
the final mold for the piece
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so essentially pouring it into into the
tube and where it's higher than the
lowest point all right it's basically a
gravity feed so the pressure of all the
silicon in the tube forces it through
them all and then it goes out into all
the small points of the skull so you
fill them all then creates the cavity
just filler silicon and that creates the
silicon that they'll applied to nectar
space so that's an impression from one
stomachs the mall there and then outside
of the mall has a silicon jacket which
has a sculpt on it to that they've
always sold for the silicon treats that
[ __ ] with silicon and that's to layer
seam to one is going to be coming out
when we redeem all this business stuff
we blend off and we're applying as a
makeup it's really edgy here's what you
hold on to then you glue it down and
then and dissolve it it's completely
seamless so you don't see any of that
there it just looks like it's creating
into the skin these are all the
different components the different
appliances that make up a complete set
of night King appliances for his makeup
so it's sculpted as a whole but we
separate it for sort of ease of
application the neck appliance is a
little bit like a sock which slips over
and covers the entire neck all the way
around we have this is a back of head
appliance with the horns we have on the
top there and we have a forehead
appliance with the horns as well these
both overlap and then we've got facial
appliance which is sort of nose and
cheeks all in one and then we have
earpieces and a separate little chin
appliance so the reason we separate the
scopes is to make it easier to mold and
run you can imagine try and run the
whole head it's been possible if it be a
mask essentially and so the idea of
breaking the makeup down is have easiest
all departments you know it's easier to
the mold run stick on stuff like that
they'll be an order of putting this on
generally you're doing next size for
sure so the neck and
and once that's on you've got back
appears that sits on legend or she's got
a channel before the face and then these
these edges will fit over top of this
page so there's a nice organized yeah so
you're kind of covering edges with other
edges they will blend on your kind of
it's making a delicate enough that it
seem less but also durable enough that
you can still handle it and still apply
it
although the phone fits that the same
page it's a bit a point for it make it
so it's blable
[Music]
so what doing here this is M of see a
live cast or the of a real human hand
may pulled out from a two-part mold and
because it's a two-part mold means that
we've got quite clean lines so I'm just
seaming it so it looks like it hasn't
been joined together and then once
you've seemed it we'll we'll paint it up
so that like a real hand and obviously
to do that from reference so we can do
it from you know the bullocks books here
as a reference but also what's amazing
is that we can use our five of our own
hands or you know other people's hands
and so you can see where the pigment the
redness is and the veins and things like
that so that definitely has we earn a
variety of techniques of painting really
quite commonly we use an airbrush and
spray on various inks and pigments and
we also used like a cut-down sort of
chip brush as something like this which
we actually did our brush into the paint
and the trees just flick it all over
which gives us a nice spatter model over
the makeup and that also helped to sort
of camouflage any little edges or
anomalies that we might have as well and
because prosthetics is all about
camouflage basically and cheating the
artwork to look like real human flesh
[Music]
something like this is probably be used
in it maybe like a bashful scene just as
like a proper we would probably go out
there with it and just maintain it kept
they tend to get quite bastard onset ads
to make sure that the paintwork is still
on at the end of the day so a few sort
of touch-ups and we also do a lot of
dressing so especially with up like this
because it's pretty big wound making
sure that it's all blood all over it and
it's you know looking as realistic as
possible rubber shoe and it's all fully
our matured as well so it's poseable and
we have the ball skirts it's got an
armature and that's that you can you can
change it its form if you if you want to
once it's all painted up and field will
hair it and the hair is individually
interested and again we can you go in
reference them you know someone else's
arms for reference we tend to use real
human hair and we have to pre turn it so
it's got a slight slight hook to it and
so it is six if it's quite nicely but I
mean we have to have that quite a lot of
this gun probably take a good day just
to sit there and individually put each
each hair in at the moment fifty masks
which are the background extras so
they'll have all the appliances and the
guys the weights that are closer to the
camera and all the main spot guys and
then just below it is as prime but it's
quicker so have a mask with that so you
can just put on if it's not going to be
shot on closely they'll have the masks
in the background and some of them I
like three or four seconds old so we
have to furbish them every year
completely and so at the moment and just
happen
doing breaking up the hairlines we six
awake from them but throughout times the
hair gets pulled out that we've punched
into the front so we just re punch it in
at the end of every season make them
look fresher
so this character is one wonder giant
who's featured in about two three
seasons of Game of Thrones he's played
by an a creature performer called VM
white who's about and seven seven foot
one inches of ink is and his makeup is
quite expensive with regards to a
department he has a big full head
prosthetic makeup with a big heavy
silicon cowl which weighs quite a lot
both the head and the shoulders and
these gloves which made out of silicon
tips here
they both attach onto a large so
lightweight phone which Burton
tribulation
uncie which said sundries costume and it
basically distorts his horns and gives
business great sort of perspective
[Applause]
which all shops are looking up again so
it's almost like a pyramid almost that
performs that created the embassy then
the costume department has made this
beautiful costume which sort of and
consists of animal pelts and all kinds
of leather bits and pieces and animal
bones and all
lovely props and things but the whole
thing weighs an absolute ton and means
very fit and healthy and so he's uh he's
able to sort of carry it all off with
Mattoon
do
it's all very stretchy and pliable and
the gloves are the same material as the
facial makeup but and everything moves
sort of quite sort of realistically
they've sort of got little extensions on
the thing that it's a little five glass
cups in there just so we can increase
the length of the fingers we've got full
coverage over the intent all the
appliances are glued on with a really
strong silicon medical additive it's all
added to the act of skin so every little
nuance a little movement comes through
the prosthetic on top and the material
so soft itself it's it's softened we say
deadened basically it's the amount of
softness in the mix of the silicon that
he just allows full facial movements of
no matter how perfectly appliance really
makeup days are always usually fairly
long the makeup time for something like
a night game is about four four half
hours we could be on set from 8:00 in
the morning to wrap that make certainly
evening during the day or we'll be
maintaining making sure that none of the
edges lift on the makeup or just making
sure that when they've had lunch and
they've got you know chips stuck in the
edge of the piece or whatever they might
happen to have we have to undo all that
and just keep it maintained really to
keep makeup looking its best
[Music]
you own the best bits about working on
things like this is getting to kind of
do the process in the workshop from
start to finish and carrying it all the
way through onto set and seeing it on
camera it makes it all worth it I love
the variety in my job it's always
creative and you get to do such a vast
quantity of different things you can go
on from one job from making someone's
old age prosthetics that does the job
when you're making that creature it's
never been something vision before
everybody who works in mr. barnman for
Barry it will always be doing their best
for Barry for the company but also for
themselves because you know you're
you're as good as your last job
brilliant away I think the satisfaction
of being responsible from designing
something to dimensionally following the
whole process all the way through really
from them doing sculpture the mold
making regenerating the prosthetic
pieces and actually being there on the
day on the set as well and gluing all
these bits of rubber to an actor and
actually seeing the filming is it's it's
just lovely to be part of the whole
process from start
you
you